okay everybody with Disney's expected
merger with Fox fans have been very
excited by the prospect of the x-men
Deadpool Fantastic Four Doctor Doom
Silver Surfer all these guys joining the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but but in the
past in the past few days we learned
that the deal might not happen so Disney
owns Marvel of course and it has offered
to buy out Fox's film and TV properties
for fifty 2.4 billion dollars but now
media giant Comcast has made a massive
counteroffer to Fox they have up
Disney's offer with a 60 billion dollar
offer now if Fox sells to Comcast for us
that would mean any hopes to see
Wolverine and Iron Man and the movie
together are dead cancelled now look
there's a lot of inside baseball
business politics involved with this but
it affects the characters and stories we
love so I thought it'd be really useful
to quickly break down how all of this
works and what that means cool everybody
cool basically there are six major media
companies that own most of the TV and
movies that you watch Disney is the
first they own Marvel Star Wars Pixar
Disney animated movies and live-action
ones like The Lion King movies coming
out so ABC shows like agents of shield
Fox owns the x-men and Deadpool
franchises Fantastic Four also alien and
avatar and all the Fox and FX shows like
The Simpsons and Legion
then there's Comcast they own Universal
Studios and the Jurassic world series
fast and furious the DreamWorks movies
NBC TV shows and technically the rights
to the Hulk movies if they ever get made
and then there's Time Warner they own
Warner Brothers in the DC movies the
harry potter and fantastic beast movies
ready player one it as well as
everything on HBO and the Turner
Broadcasting TV stuff like Adult Swim
Rick and Morty that's that's under Time
Warner Viacom owns paramount including
the Mission Impossible in Terminator
movies as well as the Comedy Central and
in TV stuff it used to own the CBS
network but CBS is technically its own
company that actually cooperates with
Warner the CW network that's a reverse
and flash all you guys and then Sony is
like the smallest one they own
spider-man and venom they in the early
days bought that over for Marvel they
also in Jumanji in the James Bond movies
now streaming services like Netflix are
shaking up this system Netflix's
permission from Marvel Comics of course
to produce TV series like the defenders
universe daredevil Jessica Jones
Punisher Netflix also produces stranger
things of course this is a really big
deal but basically we're looking at
x-men and Deadpool either joining Team
Marvel Star Wars Pixar or team Jurassic
world fantastic furious Hulk
fast and furious not fantastic though
for any Wolverine plus Hulk movie to get
made Universal would have to get like
special permission from Marvel to do
that night out Marvel would ever allow
that because they have their own very
popular Hulk and their Cinematic
Universe who can't just star in his own
movie because of this weird deal now
Marvel has agreed to a special deal with
Sony to co-produce a spider-man
homecoming series but that deal more so
benefitted Disney Marvel because of
course they could feature Spidey and
Civil War and infinity war which is huge
for them now the reason this is all
happening guys is because of money and
distribution comcast not only owns NBC
Universal but they that's the production
side they also own the massive cable
network that delivers his content to you
now Disney is trying to compete with
that they're working on a streaming
service to rival Netflix so that if you
want to watch like a Star Wars movie or
anything from Marvel or Pixar you got to
go through their app that they're gonna
announce in the next couple years
essentially comcast is trying to stay in
the game and keep Disney from absorbing
all the most popular franchises box
meanwhile is losing money because a lot
of their ties are with like print media
okay so for us this is really just a
question of what's more important is
having all of our favorite characters
under one big tent they can big make big
crossover movies together important or
is avoiding a potentially big
breatharian future where one family
friendly company filters all of our
entertainment important to us what do
you guys think laptop I mean I'm
supposed to say avoiding was it the Big
Brother in no I'm with you it's more fun
at the Iron Man that's the combo you
guys you guys always wanted 149 dollars
a month which is what they could do yeah
I think that's that's the real fear is
if imagine there's another Netflix out
there but all of your favorite movies
are on that streaming service and then
they can charge you $150 a month or a
year whatever it is you have to pay that
to be able to watch these things in your
home
I mean we're looking at a feature where
film exhibitors are you know small-town
movie theaters are closing all across
the country there's some places where
you can only watch movies on streaming
devices and if I mean there's a scary
future there's a scary version of the
future where the Marvel movie sucked at
one point you know what I mean like that
like there's not it's not an automatic
given like oh they took all the good
things it's like no they took things
that were going well so if you want your
studio to have something go invest in
good writers and directors and make good
things and hey now you'll have one too
yeah honestly like if now we wouldn't
want Disney to take over DC right
because like these are we wanted to
close the loop on Marvel and just make
the Marvel that we already know good to
its fullest and that's the reason I
think that Sam and I are probably like
it'd be fun if they could put those
characters together but aside from that
ya probably don't also own DC and also
and everything else but just make your
the best content that you can make stop
being so derivative and like oh we just
we have this property we need to make a
better movie because of the rights I'm
gonna it's like just make really good
stuff and then people go to that and
that's where we'll put our dollar so
yeah I don't mind putting I'm not loyal
to the broadcaster's whatever I'm not
loyal Netflix even I'm loyal to good
content I think the other concern might
be the fact that right now Fox has done
some really cool things allowing some of
these movies to be r-rated so you've had
some Deadpool and Logan was it was great
arguably because it was our rate and
they were allowed to explore some more
adult themes that you would never see in
an MC movie Kevin Feige I'd never make
it already I don't know if that I've
heard that I mean there have been talks
at least were like there's room for our
rated contact there is they just haven't
done it yet I mean that I think the
Netflix up is a good example of them at
least dipping their toe into it is like
you don't need to get into the
difference between like TV and the movie
sigh tomorrow but that is the MCU and
they are trying a little bit so it's not
impoverished playing yeah they would
happen in the future also it's under the
Marvel banner so it doesn't mean like
it's under the Disney ban the Disney
logo doesn't come up first the Marvel
one does even though we know where that
what that actually comes from they have
more freedom they're able to say curse
words blow the f-word in their movies
they can save a couple times at least
I'll dang it yeah exactly
any your blood search so like oh like
how could they say that
overall no this is like it either way
it's not really great like I like I know
we can just say like Disney shouldn't
own everything but both scenarios aren't
the best it like concepts Universal
shouldn't own everything either yeah I
mean if Fox is gonna go somewhere of
course rather go back with the rest of
its family rather than like weird rights
to a Hulk movie that will never get made
a universal right but let us know what
you think about this down below and
whether you'd prefer to see Deadpool in
the x-men exist in their own creative
movie universe that sometimes r-rated
and not connected to Disney and maybe
Wolverine fighting black panther is just
too cool of a possibility to turn down
if that's how you feel
which is kinda how I feel but subscribe
to new rock stars for all of our deep
dives and all the movies you love thanks
guys